harry is where this garys in new york hi
Gary welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you very much appreciate you
taking my call
sure I'm so I had a question question on
gifting I'm at a stage in my life where
I got plenty of money and I want to I
want to spread the love if you know what
I mean so I have a daughter and
son-in-law I live in Raleigh he's got a
small business repairing and building
musical instruments he's doing well he's
actually had to move once to expand his
business which is good and he's looking
at another move he wants to move farther
out of Raleigh because it's expensive
there what to rent and he wants to
basically either buy or build something
around five six thousand square feet of
commercial space so he can expand his
business I would rent all good I would
around you would let okay okay so my
wife and I have been gifting them 60,000
Kay per year that's the max you can do
without hitting the 10% gift tax and so
I was looking at maybe accelerating his
business by gifting him I was thinking
if he would be building or buying rather
than renting that I would give him the
money to do that and and do it in a way
that would avoid the taxes which is
let's say hypothetically it's three
hundred thousand I don't know what it'd
be but for something like that that I
would get basically give him a note or a
mortgage and then use the gifting that I
did from each year for him to pay that
back you know pay the loan back to me
you can just wondering what youth what
do you think of that that's done all the
time is your is your net worth under 25
million it's under it's between 10 and
20 20 okay that's in that room how old
are you
62 okay you can eat you can do the plan
you're talking about and given how high
your net worth is I probably would do
the plan you're talking about or okay
you can use up part of your estate your
federal estate tax exemption which I
believe this year is about 23 million
okay and you could use up say three
hundred thousand of that in other words
that much is exempt
from federal estate tax so if you ended
up with when you died a thirty million
dollar net where thirty million dollar
estate and you didn't do any tax
planning or any estate planning at all
you would be taxed on the difference in
the exemption or your estate would be
taxed on the simpson difference in the
exemption in the state size so thirty
million miles 23 million 7 million be
taxable and so if you use up some of
your exemption like three hundred
thousand of it and your estate continues
to grow your net worth continues to grow
and you live a while it will you could
get up you could create taxes for your
estate later okay okay but there's
another possibility is you can do what's
called a unified estate tax credit which
you use up some of your estate tax
credit while you're alive but it reduces
the amount that's covered when you die
when you die yeah yeah okay you know you
can go that way I because your net worth
is so high in your 62 you're still young
you stay size is so high you obviously
need professional estate tax planning if
you haven't gotten that yeah but okay
but but I wouldn't use up your exemption
because you are actually probably going
to break it unless tax law changes and I
don't know what tax all's going to do
who knows I mean it's gone way up under
Trump meaning that you can have a larger
estate that is not taxable so then in a
long long time so anyway that's just two
possible ways but your way you're
actually not using up any of your
exemption you're just backing off your
annuals and every year the annuals tend
to go up so you're doing your run 15
each from you and your wife to your
son-in-law 15 each from you and your
wife to your daughter and then that that
gets you to 60 but when that's 20 you
can even do more so you raise it every
year and you do a forgiveness of the
loan and the loan is never recorded and
you have n you have in your will that
that loan is forgiven at death mm-hmm so
it's never gonna be collected on right
it's just sidestepping gift taxes all
your doing
yep yep yep I know and what do you think
about it just a no not go through a full
mortgage with a lawyer but just do a
note yeah I would do a little one-page
note just something cheesy and cheap off
the internet I mean you can go to mama
bear legal forms com if you want to
download one they'll sell you one for
five bucks or something probably and
then just keep it in the file and flip
over on the back of it each year and
reduce it with handwriting and initial
it yep and that's one of your January
activities every year sounds perfect
thank you very much thank you sir
well done good question